und bevor wir jetzt über die korona
impfung und claudia absprechen wollen
wir uns aber zunächst einmal das
statement unseres bundeskanzlers olaf
scholz zu putins teilmobilmachung und
drogen und atomwaffen anschauen
die jüngsten entscheidungen der
russischen regierung sind ein akt der
verzweiflung
russland kann diesen verbrecherischen
krieg nicht gewinnen und mit den
jüngsten entscheidungen macht putin
macht russland das alles nur noch viel
schlimmer privat wenn man das jetzt
anhört wie gefährlich ist denn
eigentlich die von scholz der auch viele
medien angesprochene schwäche putins
also zunächst mal ist völlig richtig das
ist das ergebnis seiner schwäche dass er
jetzt eben doch ein schritt den er
vermeiden wollte nämlich die
teilmobilmachung aber es zeigt natürlich
auch das war ja immer auch das argument
derer die gesagt haben waffenlieferungen
werden diesen krieg nicht dazu führen
dass die ukraine in gewinnt putin hat
natürlich noch sehr viele ressourcen und
die letzte ressource die letzte karte
die gefährlichste wäre er tatsächlich
auch der einsatz taktischer atomwaffen
und ich finde es wahnsinnig gefährlich
was dort jetzt passiert und die neue
scheibe zum beispiel hat gerade
geschrieben also putin wird dann am
gefährlichsten wenn er in die ecke
gedrängt wird und umso mehr wissen wir
doch jetzt alles daran setzen dass
irgendwie verhandlungen gibt weil es ist
richtig russland kann diesen krieg sehr
wahrscheinlich militärisch nicht
gewinnen dafür ist die russische armee
zu schlecht ausgestattet aber die
ukraine kann ihn auch nicht gewinnen
weil russland wird alles daran setzen
dass sie dort keine niederlage haben und
eben im schlimmsten fall auch ihre
schrecklichsten waffen einsetzen das
heißt beide seiten können ihn nicht
gewinnen und deswegen muss man
verhandeln und es braucht ein
friedensplan und ich verstehe nicht wie
sich der westen auch die deutsche
regierung die amerikanische sowieso nur
in diese richtung verrannt haben wir
liefern immer mehr waffen immer mehr
waffen ja und wie soll das enden also
ich finde das ganz schrecklich was dort
passiert und dieses sterben muss endlich
beendet werden und jetzt werden noch
einmal mehr menschen sterben das
gegenargument ist ja dann meistens dass
das mit den atomwaffen eigentlich nur
vom putin gesagt wird uns angst zu
machen also dass er auch russische
propaganda dass er das nicht tun würde
na ja es sind ja noch mal zwei
verschiedene dinge dass eine ist dass er
atomwaffen gegen den westen einsetzt das
weiß ich nicht weil das würde auf
russland auch zurückschlagen das würde
sicherlich nur stattfinden wenn wir
direkt in diesen bringen uns hinein 10
reise kriegspartei wer aber der einsatz
taktischer atomwaffen in der ukraine
selbst ist eine eskalation die rheiner
nicht völlig auszuschließen ist und ich
denke schon dass die russische seite
wenn sie direkt vor einer niederlage
steht also bevor sie abziehen würde dass
sie dann alle karten spielt die sie hat
und dazu gehören eben auch diese
taktischen atomwaffen und ich finde man
darf sich das gar nicht ausmalen sondern
man muss jetzt alles tun das nicht immer
mehr eskalation stattfindet auch diese
schein referenten das ja auch eine
eskalation weil ein friedensplan wäre ja
wahrscheinlich darauf hinausgelaufen
dass es irgendwie autonomierechte für
den pass gibt wenn der don was aber
erstmal von russland quasi an russland
angeschlossen ist dann wird es ja viel
schwerer irgendwie eine friedenslösung
zu finden und deswegen jeder schritt der
immer weiter in dieser militärische
logik geht der kostet viele menschen
neben der zerstört ja auch in der
ukraine infrastruktur alles was dort da
sich meine wird ja kaputt gebombt ohne
ende das land ist immer mehr kaputt und
ich habe kein verständnis wenn herr
selensky sagt also er wird erst
verhandeln wenn der letzte rose von der
krim abgezogen ist weil das wird nicht
sein das ist unrealistisch und mit moral
alleine kann man keinen krieg beenden
moralisch ist das gerechtfertigt aber
moral nützt mir hier wenig ich wünsche
mir seriöse verhandlungen und ich
wünsche mir dass länder die hier eher
neutral sind da auch dann vielleicht
eine vermittelnde rolle spielen aber ich
wünsche mir auch dass die deutsche
regierung endlich sagt wir heizen das
nicht mehr militärisch man es muss einen
ausweg geben in richtung von
verhandlungen gesprächen und
kompromissbereitschaft von beiden seiten
fehler ist diese kompromissbereitschaft
überhaupt real also kann man überhaupt
davon ausgehen dass es möglich wäre zu
verhandeln im moment sehe ich das nicht
weil
die die lage wirklich noch schwieriger
ist als sie vor drei vier tage war die
neuen maßnahmen aus russland gehen ja in
die richtung diese ländereien wirklich
nun absolut zu annektieren sie zu nicht
nur besetzt zu halten sondern sie auch
zu reklamieren als eigenes land als
eigenen boden um natürlich den schluss
daraus abzuleiten dass ein angriff oder
einen wieder ein name dieser länder dann
ein angriff auf das russische
staatstheorie thorium wäre mit den
folgen die frau wagenknecht hier oder
möglichen folgen die frau wagenknecht
hier beschrieben hat nämlich möglichen
einsatz über taktische nuklearwaffen
ohne amerika würde sowieso keine
einigung in irgendeine richtung geben
das heißt bleiben sagt er auch dass er
die ukraine verteidigen will bei uns
sagt dass er die ukraine verteidigen
wird irgendwann
ist diese situation allerdings so
verfahren dass man einen solchen krieg
nicht über jahre hinweg ziehen kann weil
das sehen wir unsere wirtschaft
nachhaltig geschädigt wir sehen
natürlich auch dass die welt nicht nur
den atem anhält sondern auch immer
weiter natürlich sich dafür kämpft in
diesem dialog eben nicht dialogs und in
diesem krieg statt dialog und die frage
wird sein gibt es ein punkt wo der
westen sagt okay wir
akzeptieren zwar die jüngsten landnahme
nicht aber wir sind bereit zu sprechen
und in irgendeiner weise darauf für
putin zuzugehen bei der ja auch massiv
unter druck kommt durch china die sagen
wir brauchen waffenstillstand durch
dialog seinen verbündeten oder sagt man
wir liefern weiter waffen wir
unterstützen die ukraine weiter in der
taktischen kriegsführung und wir sehen
zu geben dass wir vielleicht in
afghanistan lösung hinbekommen wie sie
aber russland auch weil man afghanistan
diktiert haben wo sie sich nach einigen
jahren aber wieder zurückgezogen haben
auch wenn das sehr sehr lange gedauert
hat hersteller sie sind kein lied
experten sondern apple logo und virologe
aber als bürger nehmen sie die krise
natürlich auch war und auch die
statements von herrn scholz überzeugt er
sie denn haben sie vertrauen in die
regierung also aus meiner erfahrung bei
verhandlungen weiß ich dass die parteien
erst an den tisch kommen wenn das
eigentlich richtig druck gibt und man
auch unter feuer steht und ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen jetzt dass eine der
parteien an den verhandlungstisch kommt
wenn das keine notwendigkeit wenn die
panzer rollen man geländegewinne macht
dann gibt es keinen grund jetzt dem
anderen einen schritt näher zu kommen
und das muss man jetzt irgendwie
erreichen wie gesagt ich bin kein
militärexperte aber es muss eine
möglichkeit geben dass beide einsehen
dass die verhandlung die bessere lösung
ist und wie man russland da jetzt das
verkaufen kann dass die verhandlung die
bessere lösung ist das muss man sehen ob
das dann der druck ist durch die türkei
wurde der türkische präsident sagte
keiner der besetzten gebiete darf an
russland gehen hat muss alles zugegeben
werden dass man die chinesen mit ins
spiel bringt oder andere das sei
dahingestellt aber auf jeden fall muss
druck ausgeübt werden dass auch putin an
den tisch kommt x com hat mit ihm
telefoniert hatte scholz hat mit ihm
telefoniert wenn wir jetzt die hat sich
dort nichts bewegt also ich glaube
irgendwie muss was anderes passieren
vielleicht sind die waffenlieferungen
das was dort hilft herr frank glauben
sie denn als bürger dass die
waffenlieferungen dazu führen das feld
wird
ich bin wirklich kein experte ich war
noch nie in der ukraine in russland und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass man sich
dann ist nicht öffentlich äußern sollte
ich habe nur die hoffnung dass man doch
versteht dass man solche konflikte eben
verantwortungs ethisch lösen muss also
nicht gesinnungsethik schon
verantwortungs ethisch das heißt immer
das ende im blick hat und
gesinnungsethik heißt eben dass man auf
kosten der der schnell leben um moral
etwas tut was ich jetzt gerade toll
anhört als ob man viel beifall bekommt
aber was dann viel schaden anrichtet und
ich denke es war immer das zeichen guter
politik das ende zu bedenken und ich
muss sagen die letzten 20 jahre der
deutschen politik haben mich nicht
gerade überzeugt dass verantwortung
tätig da das leitmotiv ist aber ich
hoffe dass in dem falle wirklich
dringend dass man da zur vernunft kommt
und das ende bedenken